in the early decades of the 20th century
the discovery of something called
antimatter raised a significant problem
this new substance called into question
how our matter filled universe could
exist at all let me explain in 1928 Paul
Dirac came up with a new and elegant
equation to describe how particles like
electrons behaved when they travel close
to the speed of light
surprisingly Dirac found that his
equation always had two solutions sort
of how the square root of a positive
number always has two answers direct
recognize that one solution described
the electron but the other well that was
a mystery which he first dismissed as a
mathematical artifact he later said it
took him three tortured years to summon
the courage to claim that this other set
of solutions was describing something
real antimatter that is the first
solution described an electron while the
second described an anti-electron the
anti electron would have the same mass
and spin as the electron but it would
have an opposite electric charge now
since the electron has a negative charge
the anti electron would have a positive
charge which is why we also call it a
positron Dirac's equation says the same
thing is true for all particles quarks
have anti quarks and just as quarks can
make up protons anti quarks can make up
anti protons and antiprotons and
anti-electron x' they can make anti
atoms and so on
Dirac's theory was a remarkable
achievement if proven correct it would
double the number of known particles in
the world just four years later in 1932
Carl Anderson took this picture of a
particle racing through a bubble chamber
his measurements showed that it had the
same masses in
electron but a positive electric charge
the first detection of antimatter
verifying directs mathematical
prediction now we come to the puzzle
when matter and antimatter come together
they annihilate and this raises a big
question why is there any matter left
after all if matter and antimatter are
identical except for having opposite
electric charge and since as far as we
can tell the laws of physics don't have
a preference for a plus sign over a
minus sign we would expect equal amounts
of matter and antimatter to be created
at the Big Bang
and then as they intermingled the matter
and antimatter would all annihilate
leaving a sea of structureless radiation
but if this were the case the universe
as we know it wouldn't exist so what's
going on physicists have been puzzling
about this for more than half a century
some have wondered whether the
antimatter got separated from matter and
might still be out there existing as
anti planets anti stars anti galaxies
maybe even anti universes others have
imagined that just after the Big Bang a
tiny imbalance between matter and
antimatter somehow crept in indeed to
avoid total annihilation scientists have
calculated that for every billion anti
protons there must have been a billion
plus one protons that's a tiny imbalance
but it would have left over just enough
matter to make all we see in the
universe today to figure out which if
any of these theories might be right
scientists are undertaking a range of
experiments to understand ant
matter with far greater precision and
all this is part of a grand quest to
answer a question that is as simple as
it is profound given that matter and
antimatter annihilate how is it that we
exist
[Music]
thank you very much good evening so that
is the question why do we exist now let
me just quickly say at the outset that
sounds pretty heavy right it sounds like
it's a question of existential angst
that we're going to be dealing with here
tonight but as the animation makes clear
we mean it in the most flat-footed
direct interpretation of the words how
is it that there still is matter around
if there was equal matter and antimatter
early on why didn't it all annihilate
leaving nothing that's the issue that
we're going to take up here tonight and
we have some of the world's greatest
experts on these ideas joining us for
this conversation so let's get right to
it and bring them on to the stage our
first participant is a physicist who is
a founding director of the Kavli
Institute for physics and mathematics of
the universe at the University of Tokyo
he received the UK of commemoration
prize in 2002 and a home built research
award in 2017
please welcome Hitoshi Murray Amma
[Music]
also joining us is a physics professor
at MIT was the member of the micro Boone
and ice cube experiments she's a fellow
of the American Physical Society and
received the Maria coffered my reward
for her leadership and experimental
neutrino physics please welcome Janet
Conrad our third participant is the
research physicist at CERN where he is a
spokesperson of the edgiest experiment
he's also one of the editors of Physics
Letters B and also contributed the
review of particle properties please
welcome Michael dozer all right next to
join us is a distinguished scientist at
Fermilab and a professor of physics at
the University of Chicago and the Enrico
Fermi Institute and an internationally
renowned expert on particle physics
please welcome Marcela Karina
and our final participant is the
director of the Perimeter Institute for
Theoretical Physics in Ontario Canada
and a founder and chair of the African
Institute for mathematical sciences and
award-winning physicists who developed
and test theories of the early universe
please welcome Neil Turok alright so
welcome to you all and you know just a
quick aside you know there aren't that
many physicists in the world so we all
know each other at one level or another
you know and I actually bring that up to
this guy in the air he's going like this
but let me tell you what that means do
you know when I met you first yes 33
years ago Italy in Italy in a reach a
you were my teacher at the so it's a
pleasure to have all of you here to take
up a question that people have been
puzzling about for for a very long time
and so let's get right into the subject
which really does begin with Paul Dirac
and maybe Nia can just start us going
what was direct puzzling about that
ultimately led to him writing down this
equation that has driven so much of
theoretical physics
so Dirac was very odd person and
actually in the same school that we met
in I met Dirac when I was a student
oh is that right yes and there's a
biography of him called a strangest man
and he pretty much was he came to the
school with his wife but they would
never be seen together I had breakfast
separately you know she was this she I
do that with my wife thank you saw she
went off to the left right
that's right but no Dirac was very
obsessive individual he came to the
school where there were a lot of other
very distinguished figures in physics
and they were all talking about the
glorious days of physics and how
wonderful physics was and all that
trying to inspire all the students and
Dirac basically said you know the Golden
Age of physics was the 1920s and it's
come and gone and you're all too late
[Laughter]
the the school the school was I think 83
yeah 83 so yeah what did Dirac do so
Dirac was obviously genius and he took
on the task of unifying relativity which
Einstein had invented with quantum
mechanics which bore and other people
had invented and somehow nobody else
could manage in the way directed he had
a precision and the clarity and a
simplicity about his work that was just
stunning and so whenever people had
paradoxes or problems with quantum
mechanics you know they would always
turn to Dirac what do you say about this
he wrote down this equation that
achieved that goal yes but as the story
goes and I believe the story is true we
sort of see the acquit you don't have to
know what this means of course but this
is the Dirac equation in a simple form
yes I think we may even have it you know
notation in physics can hide a great
degree of complexity do have a more
spelled out version of it yeah there we
go simplified version too right I wanted
to draw the full one but I ran out of
time on doing everything but um so he
writes in this equation and it makes a
strange prediction I would like to say
that when any of you is looking at that
equation
might be you know a bit push backwards
because doesn't look so easy but I would
like to make the analogy if you are not
a trained musician and if you are
looking at the notes on stave they will
not really talk to you very strongly but
then if you have a virtuoso who comes
and interprets this music then you will
have an amazing melody coming out of it
so the same way I would say that this I
read equation that you are looking at
there from your perspective was powerful
enlightening for someone of the genius
of Dirac and out of that equation
he basically predicted the whole anti
world and so I would say that one has to
think about that when when one looks at
equations mathematicians and physicists
might have a take on it but the beauty
of this equation is something that we as
scientists should try to convey to you
in many different ways as the music as
the musicians and the dancers do with
their interpretations does that analogy
give us a way of thinking about Dirac's
resistance to the prediction of his own
equations because you're right he writes
down this equation it does put special
relativity and quantum mechanics
together out of the math there is this
strange prediction there as we sort of
said in the animation there are two
solutions when they really only should
be one and he doesn't believe it would
that be like Bach writing a fugue and
then like
[Laughter]
yes now you also have to cast your minds
back because in those days people were
more parsimonious
with adding new particles in the world
and I say that as someone who's part of
a field that's added a lot of particles
that have never been seen in the world
but in those days to do this was a
radical move very right so I'm just
wondering if you put yourself interact
shoes and imagine that you write down
this equation I know what I would have
done I think I would have thrown it away
I would have said it's predicting these
other particles they don't exist and
therefore something's wrong exactly do
you do you think you'd have the well I
will be scared actually no one had ever
predicted a particle in that way before
yeah and actually what happened is they
try many of the physicists that we're
trying to understand and discuss with
Iraq it took three years for him to
really finally accept that what he has
predicted was a new type of particle
that was not there before and there has
not yet been discovered yeah that's very
important so the beginning he thought
maybe you know that was a proton so then
they thought maybe something different
okay and so it took him quite some time
and we think three years is a lot but
maybe maybe we think about that we will
come back maybe later about the Higgs
mechanism that took fifty years pretty
fast he was kind of lucky in in first of
all recognizing that that was a new anti
world in front of him and then actually
a year later so only four years after
the first antiparticle the first
positron was actually discovered yes why
don't we talk about that
without that I don't think we would be
having this conversation here however
beautiful the equations were and Dirac
was very fond of saying math is
beautiful and that's why it really
describes the world but it has to be
data so so Janet wanted to give us a
sense of when was this confirmed and how
is it done
well the confirmation of it was
happening actually you can see on the
screen in this in this cloud chamber
picture which shows the the event that
do you want to speak to this one which
other well this is actually a cloud
chamber and this was the first time that
a positron to tell us what the cloud
chanting everybody knows so basically
it's like air and vapor can condense
when a particle goes through there are
some vacuum and some electric fields and
magnetic fields and so basically when a
particle goes you give a tract of paper
of liquid and on something that is
basically air okay and that's what you
see there so this is the trace is the
trace of a positron and one can decide
many things there but the point is that
because of the magnetic field D and
because of what they understood after a
while also that you know Carl Anderson
was the one who discovered the positron
and Caltech and the point was that they
were also confused about well maybe you
know this was a particle that actually
comes from a decay of cosmic rays so it
comes from the outer atmosphere makes it
up to here and so they were thinking
well maybe you know the we don't know
where the is an electron that is bending
in the wrong direction
that was the but maybe the electron is
coming upwards instead of downwards and
then that would be okay or maybe the
positron that we already know at that
time we only knew positrons and
electrons
maybe suppose it's wrong with the right
charged positrons are charged like
protons protons and positrons have the
same positive charge so maybe it's a
proton that is coming there
and it took some time and car and Rizzo
had to basically improve a lot his
device
yeah in order to be able to recruit ibly
show that this was for the first time
the trace of antimatter in this case a
positron so an anti-electron
it took quite a little while to improve
them the the instrument and I always get
very impressed about you know Janet is
an experimentalist and here Michael as
well so I think it's humbling to see
what our colleagues experimentalist can
do to learn about nature yep so Janet
well I I thought that maybe you all
would like to find your own positrons so
everybody should have a little envelope
I hope you all have an envelope and
inside of the envelope is some bubble
chamber film everybody should have one
piece of bubble chamber film every image
is different this is actually film I'm
sorry what happens was that there was a
very large bubble chamber at to Fermilab
so what happens with the bubble chamber
is you have a compressed liquid and when
charged particles go through it they
create little bubbles then when you
decompress the bubbles become large and
you can actually take a photograph of it
and there's a magnetic field and so
that's what causes the particles to spin
around in the picture so every event is
different you all can take a look
somewhere in their neutrino interactions
if you can go ahead and find them but
what we thought you would really like to
see is where energy turns into a int
matter an antimatter pair so this
happens in this picture that you have up
here you can see it right there so just
tell us exactly what we're seeing there
right out of nothing which was actually
a photon so that's a little packet of
energy which is not electrically charged
so you can't actually see it in your
detector suddenly it converts into an
electron and a positron and because we
have a magnetic field what happens is
that the positive charge spins one
direction and the negative charge spins
the other direction so what you get is
you get a little vertex and then you
have the particle traveling in one
direction and the anti particle
traveling in the other direction and
that's how we see antimatter in our
detectors and we know that it's
antimatter fantastic and there should be
at least one in every image there's a
lot of photons that come out that
actually found your electron-positron
pair find it you know when Dirac had to
dismiss his own solution because he was
so scared to say there's antimatter
he must be also very nervous for an
experimentalist to claim they discovered
antimatter oh yeah
oh is it like you know being an explorer
run for this when when you think you
might have found something new you spend
a lot of time playing with it and trying
to make sure that it is exactly what it
is that you you think it is and you have
to look at something in many different
ways because we have a problem in
experiment with something which is
called background which is where you see
things that just look similar to what at
this signal that you're looking for
right well the example that I like to
give is let's say you are looking for
women with red hair and you wanted to
count the number of redheaded women
there are in the world and you go out
and you count and you discover that
there are many more redheaded women than
you ever expected and and that's because
of lore'l
so all those redheaded women where the
that are not really redheaded are the
background to worry about that exactly
when you're looking for things like this
including when you're looking for
antimatter so there you find the the
anti electron the positron and it takes
a couple decades before the next element
of the antimatter part of the world is
dispersed it's really easy to get an
electron so they they rain down on you
constantly but it's like right now like
right now yeah in fact if you have a
banana
does anybody have a banana in their
pocket I don't want to hear the airing
that during the hour that you're gonna
listen to us you're that one
anti-electron is gonna appear inside
that banana so just to give you an idea
it's very simple to get an electron if
you want something more massive like an
antiproton you're gonna have to put a
lot more energy into it than you can get
simply from waiting for banana to do
something interesting so you have to
build an accelerator you have to build
something that will give you start out
with a proton you accelerate it you go
to higher and higher and energy until
you have enough energy to actually pair
produce because again you have to
produce two particles yes there's a
equals MC squared this equals MC squared
but you also have to conserve charges
you have to get both at the same time
and then if you have just enough energy
if you build your accelerator just right
you can produce an antiproton and when
did that happen
did that that was in 1955 at Berkeley
and the main problem again is the the
Loreal effect you get many many more
particles that are produced at the same
time as the antiproton so you have to
actually produce an antiproton and prove
that you've made an antiproton
and what you see in the picture on the
right hand side is what happens when an
antiproton that interacts with the
photographic emulsion
as it touches the emulsion as matter
meets antimatter it annihilates and in
the case of a positron it's not so
spectacular it will go into two photons
here if an antiproton touches a nucleus
it basically rips apart the nucleus and
these fragments go flying all over the
place and leave traces in the
photographic emulsion right so these are
now examples of finding an anti-electron
and antiproton from them raining down in
some form or another how about in
controlled experiments in the laboratory
is this now something that we can do to
actually create in fact this this
machine is just the predecessor of a
machine that's now running at CERN a
factory to make antimatter and again all
it takes is having a little bottle of
hydrogen you accelerate the protons
after you have it ripped apart the
hydrogen into a proton electron go up to
high enough energy you produce anti
protons the real problem then is you've
made the anti protons and as you want to
study them and they annihilate so that's
not exact options antimatter through
that process can we bring up that video
of the great thank you Motech so this is
really a it's a video of the world's
only antimatter factory which is at CERN
or antiproton Factory actually and it
starts out with a bottle of hydrogen you
take the hydrogen you rip it apart in
electric field then through a series of
electric and magnetic fields you give it
more and more energy until it has enough
energy to be able to smack to be smashed
into a block of iridium at that point
when it hits the iridium the kinetic
energy is transformed into pairs of
particles and antiparticles there's a
picture of this target which i think is
nice to see because it really this all
stems from the 1970s 1950s 1970s so you
really see the technology as it was at
that time this is still the same source
that we're using it's still the same
apparatus now once you have that the
anti protons that are produced are
moving almost at the speed of light
because the protons are moving so fast
and you you push them forward and in
order to actually study them you have to
catch them yeah and catching them that's
the real hard part because they're
moving so fast you have to first slow
them down so you need another
accelerator that's run backwards
that's the antiproton decelerator rather
than accelerator and this thing slows
the antiprotons down from the speed of
light down to one tenth the speed of
light it's as slow as you can go this is
practically pedestrian speed for
physicists
at that point you can just barely catch
these antiprotons you can start hoping
to catch a few but percent of the
antiprotons that come out and then how
do you actually hold on to them right I
mean very carefully because you have to
avoid that they touch matter obviously
so you're going to be doing this in
vacuum you can manipulate the trapped
antiprotons
once you've trapped them with electric
fields and magnetic field so you sort of
touched them at a distance while keeping
them well in the center of a series of
rings these rings are all connected to
batteries each one is connected to
different voltage and that allows you to
create sort of potential landscapes like
marbles these antiprotons will roll
around in this landscape and you can
raise hills move things around so is
this something that we can create large
quantities of it yeah enormous
quantities I mean 10 million antiprotons
in a go like what is the 10 million and
type facility and this is really top of
the line facility for a whole year
you're gonna end up with 10 to the 14
antiprotons which is like really big
numbers except but like how many I'm
just wondering like how many how many
atoms why few more than I was gonna go
up with it 1 gram is Avogadro's number
so it's times 10 to the 23 10 to the 20
means you're making a tenth of a nano
gram of antimatter per year right
so so actually not that I want to be you
know the friendly competitor being here
at Fermilab so in this side of the
country
but I I'm sure you remember the movie
Angels & Demons that was there in 2009
and at that time here in the US we still
have the Tevatron running and so that
was the biggest antimatter Factory in
the world okay and at that time I did
this little calculation because that
question was asked about you know can we
really blow up the Vatican as you know
as they were telling us in this gorgeous
movie and you know Victoria Vitra and
Robert Lancome has to save the Vatican
so much let's you know the law is
because you brought up the film
independently of my prodding you we can
now fair you show a little little clip
of it so you have that little section
extremely combustible substance called
antimatter we need to locate it
immediately or evacuate Vatican City
I've never heard of antimatter being
used as such well it's never been
generated in significant quantities
before it's a way of studying the
origins of the universe when I was the
movie and the most amazing guy found his
movies that these people made a quarter
gram of antimatter and the
director-general didn't know the status
and they must have spent enormous power
that must have cost them billion
trillion trillion dollars and the
director didn't notice it right so not a
huge budget or at CERN it actually takes
the age of the universe to get enough
antimatter this little calculation that
it will take really a hundred million
years to make the amount of the quarter
gram of antimatter it will cost the very
little amount of money of five five
hundred trillion dollars you know I
don't have it in my pocket but I can get
it tomorrow and most interesting I mean
I was thinking by living at CERN and
going through the Swiss border many
times that how they do smuggle it from
CERN to the Vatican because you know
this could be you were talking about
this trap this could be of the size of a
football field
so actually the track wouldn't have to
be that big because the thing is of
course if you can work with charged
particles you need massive electric
fields and massive magnetic fields but
if you transform this into atoms you can
trap those and you don't need these
enormous a gram of hydrogen you can hold
in a bottle about actually I have to
make it into anti hydrogen first that's
the tricky part I thought anti hydrogen
if you do it it will be very extremely
hard and it's seemly unstable correct no
it's actually easy to easy to make the
experiment but to actually keep it safe
to transport it through and you know go
this is a really fascinating
conversation here but if you don't mind
we'll leave that angel name an issue to
later conversation let's um let's get
back to the UM the issue at hand so
let's see so we've got we got antimatter
and matter we can actually produce it in
various quantities up at the the the
puzzle that we're really focused on here
tonight is how is it that the universe
was able to create matter and antimatter
and yet somehow there's this matter left
around us so so from that perspective
the first person to really give us
insight into this was a russian
dissident andre soccer many want to give
us a rough sense and then we can have a
little visual we can discuss what he
told us was a physicist in russia back
in the soviet union days and he was in a
pro-democracy person he was like to
present many times back in those days
but he came up this wonderful idea that
maybe you know universe had a way of
keeping matter but throwing away
antimatter and so what he did is that
well when universe start with a big man
the huge amount of energy turned into
matter but as we just heard from Janet
whenever energy turns into matter
there's also an accompanying antimatter
always one-to-one yep
if we stayed that way when any of us
becomes bigger and colder and eventually
matter and antimatter meet and again
one-to-one they go puff and disappear
yeah so he pointed out that if there is
some tiny difference between the way
matter behaves and antimatter be faiths
maybe they could be tiny difference
between them so if they start with a
billion two billion maybe one part of a
billion antimatter turns into matter
and then there's a small difference
between them when they meet pretty much
everybody disappears but they remain
just the tiny bit of it left
ocular so your numbers were a billion
say antiprotons right today - a billion
plus one proton and you had that little
imbalance leaving us one particle
leftover for every billion of these guys
that's right you claim that would be
enough if that imbalance to give rise to
everything that I see in the world
around so we actually live here at the
expense of billion friends right gotta
be really great for them so sakarov
actually laid out a set of conditions
that didn't necessarily yield a very
specific theory that would yield that
imbalance but a set of criteria that if
you could meet would give you a shooting
a fighting chance of having this
scenario that who told you describe
worked out so let's just take a quick
look just to get a feel for what it is
that sakarov had found so if we can look
at that little sequence where we start
with the big bang as you mentioned
energy is creative yields equal amounts
of matter and antimatter and now we want
to somehow go forward in time and pass
through some process you can go on to
the next slide if you would wear this
black box process well somehow give rise
to this imbalance that you're talking
about that we'll leave over just matter
you can go on to the next one
as opposed to antimatter so the question
he asked is what in the world is
happening inside that black box that's
the real issue and to give you a feel
for what he found we're just gonna do a
little announced a little silly analogy
but nevertheless I think it give you a
flavor for what it is that he found
instead of talking about particles and
antiparticles we're gonna talk about
instead rabbits and anti rabbits and
imagine that you have and I'll talk you
through this so please don't advance
until I tell you to advance so in fact
this is why they gave me a little
clicker I was a little bit slow on the
uptake if you can just step back if you
would one slide that would be great so
imagine you begin
the equal numbers of rabbits and anti
rabbits so in the animation is we get so
we got two of them they pass through the
black box and we have now more rabbits
and more anti rabbits that means that
we're allowing the numbers of these
particles or in this case these rabbits
to change if you can't change the number
of protons or anti protons then you're
dead because if you start with equal
numbers and they can't change they're
always going to be equal numbers but if
they change in the way illustrated here
you still have symmetry you still have
the same number of orange rabbits as
blue rabbits so you don't have the
imbalance that hit oh she was talking to
so if we look at the next criterion we
want to now start with the two rabbits
and two anti rabbits but want them to
pass through the black box in such a way
that the number of rabbits differs from
the number of anti rabbits if we could
do that then we'd have the imbalance
that Vitosha was talking about and that
gives us a chance of explaining why
there's matter left over the extra
orange rabbits the extra rabbits as
opposed to anti rabbits now the question
let me just quickly show it in in the
language of particle physics so imagine
we have equal numbers let's call it X
matter and antimatter would pass through
the black box and somehow yield that
kind of imbalance that is the goal of
the black box and what theorists have
been trying to do for a very long time
is fill in the details of the black box
to try to come up with a mechanism that
allowed that to happen and clearly one
of the things that needs to happen if
there has to be some kind of a symmetry
between matter and antimatter and that
takes us but who taught you how to
comment I want to get to that first but
then we'll talk about some of the
experimental work that's been trying to
find differences between matter and
antimatter that might allow us to
realize the black box but it's a little
comment I want to make was I was happy
that you didn't use anti-human for this
yeah you just arrived it's right
I thought about humans first climate
would be an obvious choice there was a
choice of color though that
subconsciously aligned with that
decision okay anyway so moving on so so
Michael you've certainly been spending
part of your career and trying to find
differences between matter and
antimatter I know you've done a variety
experiment you just sort of go through
some of the possibilty sector so
basically what you're trying to do is
look for a tiny imbalance you're trying
to see a tiny difference between matter
and antimatter and by tiny it's a part
in a billion a part in a trillion who
knows how small this difference can be
and so if you're trying to measure this
kind of difference with charged
particles you can do that I mean one of
the experiments the the base experiment
for example at CERN is doing that by
measuring the properties of anti protons
as they move around inside a magnetic
field but at some point you're gonna hit
some limit the systematic limit you
can't measure your magnetic field that
precisely so the ultimate precision that
you can try to reach is not with working
with charged particles but actually
working with neutral antimatter neutral
systems like atoms and atoms are really
great because they're you can use lasers
to probe the atoms you can measure
extremely precisely so there's been an
experiment the ALF experiment has been
measuring the light that's emitted by
anti hydrogen atoms anti hydrogen and to
hide it so what is so how would you
build an mm what is it you put two bits
together it's it's really simple you
take an antiproton take an anti-electron
you put them together
you're a theorist right so that should
be and it's it's taken while 10 years of
hard work to make atoms that's what
we're looking at right here that's what
the atom looks like symbolic is speaking
one of the first experiments to build
the anti hydrogen atom was the Athena
experiment in 2002 it took almost 10
years before between making the first
atom and actually being able to hang on
to it to trap it because once you made
it it's neutral your electric field your
magnetic fields are useless it just goes
off I see like for the for the
antiproton you
with in it with the electric opinion
with with magnetic field you hold it yep
you're very very strong fields it's very
hard to hold on to these atoms but the
alpha experiment managed to do that in
2010 and since then they've been
shooting everything they've got at these
atoms laser light microwaves anything
you can do to manipulate these atoms and
measure their you're trying to basically
hit it with the laser excited exact at a
anti electron to jump up a little bit
fall back down as it falls back down it
releases some some light some night
light and you can see where that you do
that with hydrogen as well you do a
comparative study and you can be
sensitive at one part in 100 million
hundred billion hundred trillion depends
how far you want to go with this and
what kind of transition you're looking
at in the hydrogen the anti hydrogen
very creative very by the way the to
transition these two arrows that are
shown there they both lit two Nobel
Prizes Ramsey on the right hand side and
hench on the left hand side so it's it's
a business where you can hope to get a
Nobel Prize which is the ultimate driver
right this is one thing you can do you
can try to look at the light and
microwave is just another form of but
just so we understand this I guess what
you're saying is you're looking at sort
of the the energetic difference between
those horizontal lines exactly that's
telling you the energy of the light
that's being emitted so were there a
difference between those separations you
would have found the goal that you were
looking for which is the difference
between you is one difference it might
not be the one that is the cause of what
we're actually trying to understand it
would certainly be really exciting and
have you found any no of course not
you'd have heard about it in the news
Media would have been all over this now
you guys are also doing if I understand
some experiments with gravity right see
how so-so antimatter many people would
think it must fall up instead of fall
down yeah so tell us a little bit about
the idea there is to also test the
fundamental symmetry to see if there's a
difference between matter and antimatter
gravity is really hard to test with
particles so again you work with neutral
systems and there the hope is again that
you might find a difference now that
hope is even more remote than trying to
find a difference in the light spectra
because there's absolutely no theory
that predicts any difference or
accommodates it or could transform a
difference in gravity to an asymmetry in
the universe except Ito XI he's the only
one who's managed to write a paper about
it as far as I know see I'm off the
Nobel Prize to write I thought it's
never get Nobel Prizes and the basic
reason for that I gather is in in
Einstein's general relativity if we go
to our most refined description of
gravity gravity responds to energy right
so if matter and antimatter have the
same energy then gravity seems to treat
them at least on paper in exactly the
same way and in fact we know that if you
drop a lead brick and a plastic bottle
they fall exactly at the same speed it's
something that's been tested extremely
precisely by Adelberg a-- for example
way way more precisely than what we can
hope to do because to actually drop
antimatter the way we would like to do
it like Galileo dropped well a lead
brick from the Tower of Pisa requires
having very very cold anti hydrogen it
has to have a temperature about a
millionth of a degree above absolute
zero and even then the best you can do
is a measurement of about a percent
precision so it's gonna take many many
years until we get there and this
experiment underway or is it yeah there
are three experiments that are underway
my experiment the aegis experiment
that's trying a different approach it's
not gonna drop atoms off a tower we're
actually gonna shoot them out like like
cannons out of a cannon that's our Ken
balls out of a cannon and watch the para
ball measure the parabolic trajectory so
that's that's the Aegis experiments
approach there are two others the Alpha
experiment has got
just tell me a little bit more about
this you're gonna fire these in some
manner that that is giving us a cartoon
version of and you're gonna track their
trajectories and determine whether the
actual trajectory differs for a matter
versus that's right so you shoot them
out at maybe a thousand miles an hour
sorry a second a little bit faster you
can typically fly them over about a
meter that's sort of the distance that
we've got room for and so they fly for a
millisecond they drop for a millisecond
and in a millisecond they drop by well a
tenth of my very thin hair so it's
really really hard to measure the size
thing but we'll get there at some point
so the theorists in the group do you
have hope that that experiment is going
to yield a positive outcome or do you
think it's not answer I would love it to
but I think it's unlikely right okay
thank you very much so so Janet and
Toshi you guys have been thinking about
a distinct kind of probe of antimatter
in some sense a more subtle probe which
has to do with other particles called
neutrinos right Janet just give us a
sense of why what are neutrinos quickly
and then why would they be a good place
to look
so neutrinos are among the fundamental
particles that we have in the standard
model one of our embarrassing problems
that we have with the standard model is
we have a lot of fundamental particles
you would like to have your theory be
more elegant and but they are among the
fundamental particles that we have there
and they're really interesting particles
because they carry no electric charge
and so as a result they are not as
affected by all of the different for all
of the different things that are going
on around them where they may be
affected by electric fields or magnetic
fields or something like that I'd like
to think of them as a very quiet
particle and if you're looking for
something which is very subtle it's best
to look in a quiet place and so the
neutrinos allow you to be able to look
for unexpected behavior
because already they are doing things
which are really very rare that's a
question about that just hopefully
understand the main diagnostic that we
had on the table for talking about
matter versus antimatter was the
electric charge of the particle if
neutrinos don't have electric charge how
do we talk about antimatter and matter
so we have neutrinos and we have anti
neutrinos we believe because they we
have particles that decay and the
particles which are matter particles
that decay into the neutrinos produce
the neutrino the antimatter produces the
anti neutrino that's what we believe in
fact it is possible that the neutrino is
its own antiparticle and in fact this is
something that Hoshi has been spending a
lot of time looking at and so you yeah
so they so the reason why we think that
neutrinos might actually saved us from
this great annihilation after big man
yeah is that when the big man made is
the same amount of matter and antimatter
and you you want to turn a bit of
antimatter into matter that's some more
the matter with ducks or survive right
but if you want to change antimatter if
that has electric charge there's a plus
then you can turn that into matter that
should have charged minus or minus two
plus it doesn't happen right but if this
were neutrino neutral has charged zero
and it can turn into anti neutrino with
charge - Co that's also zero so neutral
is the only product I can imagine that
can sort of go back and forth between
matter and antimatter so that it created
on this little bit of a symmetry between
the two so then neutrinos are we
actually super heroes that saved us from
this complete annihilation
that sounds very enticing right so let
lets so that that certainly motivates us
to think about this issue now you guys
have been looking at some distinctions
between matter and antimatter
in the neutrino sector of the world and
in a probe that you've been using uses
something called neutrino oscillation
tell us a little bit about what that is
well first of all I need to mention that
nutrition is a subtle as Janet said and
they are so subtle that there are
actually trillions of them going to a
body every second through your body
actually does anybody feel that if
anybody does I recommended to go to see
a doctor tonight so you know you don't
feel them right they're so shy so for
experimental eyes like Janet it's
incredibly hard to study them because
you can catch them very easily
but fortunately neutrinos do something
really really amazing first of all they
come in what we call three flavors so
they come with like strawberry chocolate
and the pistachio
yeah but why the Newton is describing
some space they what strawberry
chocolate
[Laughter]
do what I have a debate on so the thing
is that when you have less is strawberry
neutrinos they're going through space
then it starts to turn into chocolate
and that's what people discovered so can
we bring it forward go to the animation
just one question because I love
analogies obviously can you hold off on
that not just yet just you hold that for
one second I think about these neutrinos
and and the flavors that you're using to
describe them in what physical ways
would they actually potentially differ
from yeah so let's say the chocolate
flavor neutrino can produce an electron
and straw be a flavor of the neutrino
can put you sort of heavier version
electron called muon so different flavor
of neutrinos when they interact with
matter produces different kinds of
particle how about the new trainers
themselves would they all have the same
mass or what about that you know new
stress is a really weird thing so they
do have mass and that's a great
discovery that was awarded Nobel Prize
couple years ago but at the same time
they are sort of a mixed up in a strange
way yeah so if we take one neutrino it's
a mixture of three flavours it's a very
very strange particle so if you have one
of these in your hand it could at one in
the same moment be a combination right
that's right and that's one of the
weirdnesses of quantum mechanics that
things can sort of be a mixture of here
and there the mixture is spinning this
way and that way a mixture of being
chocolate and strawberry that's right
yeah all right so so take us through
what you were gonna describe yeah that's
right so let's say Homer Simpson orders
a strawberry chocolate and he's waiting
at the counter guys thank you
and then why did they I scream is coming
towards him it starts to turn into
chocolate and complete now with the
chocolate and starts to interact into
strawberry now back completed strawberry
what was doing back and forth eventually
they're gonna be mixed up like this
right so what he's gonna find is the
mixture of chocolate and strawberry and
what experimental state is that they
were just looking for strawberry
neutrinos
so the detector that was very good at
detecting that kind of arena but not the
chocolate and then they're waiting for
strawberries arrive but when they
actually got the nutrients in the hand
they were very surprised because they
thought half what the more lost and they
don't have them lost because half them
in turn the chocolate
they couldn't taste right so the homo
was shocked right so he's bitterly
complaining about that and this is
called neutrino oscillations that as the
neutrino travels through space its
identity can actually shift between
these three possibilities right right so
given that neutrinos can do that how
would you go about determining if anti
neutrinos might behave differently
because after all that's where after a
difference between matter and antimatter
nutrients an antigen is now Jana you're
doing an experiment as I understand that
that is aimed at trying to find that
kind of a difference want to take this
for those ideas so the way that you do
this is you actually begin by running a
beam that only has neutrinos and you
look for a neutrinos to do their little
dance and change from one type to the
other and then you run the experiment
again but the next time you go ahead and
you make anti neutrinos so first let me
tell you a little bit about how we make
a beam and then I'll tell you how you do
the difference between this so think so
you make these as an accelerator for
example at Fermi National Accelerator
Laboratory which is a place that you can
go and visit if you want to it's open to
the public and people are very welcome
to visit it and again we begin with
hydrogen and it we put a big voltage
across it basically like a lightning
bolt and out comes the protons and the
protons travel along our accelerator and
we want to have those protons go faster
and faster and so what we do is we have
them surf they surf on a radio frequency
wave but very much like a surfer in
Hawaii might be surfing if you catch the
bigger and bigger wave you go you get
more and more energy you go faster and
faster and you approach the speed of
light so these go around the ring they
come out they run into a target
the target when the proton set the
target
there's an explosion of particles that
come out and some of those decay to
neutrinos those neutrinos we want to
send to a detector that's very far away
so there's plenty of time for them to do
their little dance so we have to send
them through the ground actually that
means you have to send your neutrinos
under the ground and it will go through
the earth and it will show up from an
accelerator that's outside of Chicago
it'll show up in a gold mine in South
Dakota that's the plan
and how it's about a thousand thousand
kilometers and so during that time the
neutrinos will do their little dance and
you would start out with neutrinos that
were one particular flavor and at the
end hopefully you see another flavor in
your detector now that's if you're going
to make a neutrino beam what you want to
do is you want to have all of the
particles that decay to neutrinos be
pointed forward into the earth towards
your detector and so if you take a look
at your bubble chamber picture again you
notice that the the matter is spinning
in one direction the antimatter is
spinning in the other direction that's
because there's a magnetic field so if I
want to pick out matter all I need to do
is put on a magnetic field and that
sends any antimatter I create going off
some other direction not pointed in the
direction of my detector and so the
particles that are going to decay to
produce neutrinos then go off and decay
and produce the particles that I would
like to look at now if I want to switch
all I have to do is reverse my magnetic
field now all my matter will go off in
one direction and my antimatter will go
toward my detector a battle decay into
the neutrinos that I'm actually looking
for in my detector and the neat thing
about this detector is actually it is
really the the descendant of the bubble
chamber we think of it as a sort of an
electronic bubble chamber that we're
building it's a state-of-the-art
detector and it is going to be 40
kilotons so it is a ver
very large detector that we have to
build it will be one of the largest of
this type of detector looking for this
question once we've actually built it
but there is actually an experiment
running today in Japan that is working
on the same ideas and I suggest that all
of you pay attention and about a week
because we're having a big conference
it's called neutrino 2018 it's where we
present all of our results and we
suspect that a big result is going to
come out of from the group from Japan
although I I don't know what it is
secret yeah I don't know what it is I
really don't know the doors are locked
in the audience so as of today just to
get the experimental stage repairs the
experiments that you guys have been
involved with has it yielded any
asymmetry so that's so there are hints
of an asymmetry that are coming from
this experiment that was running in
Japan two years ago at the same big
conference they showed a little bit of a
difference and so we suspect that they
will be showing a bigger difference at
this next conference and I think it will
not quite meet the level that we use in
science to kala discovery which is why I
think we need this experiment that we
want to run at Fermilab but it looks
like it is likely that the anti neutrino
does this little dance differently from
the neutrino and if that's true and this
kind of thing was happening in the early
universe you can actually get matter
antimatter let me ask you a question
about that because just to be clear as
many people perhaps already know there
have been signatures of an asymmetry
between matter and
that had been on the table for some time
anyone want to speak to that situation
so the problem with all of the ones that
we have seen so far so we have we have
seen evidence of this in what's called
the quarks the quarks are what actually
makes up the proton and the neutron
they're the other two another type of
fundamental particle but they're the
effects that we've seen we have seen
differences but the effects we've seen
are are too small to explain the level
of matter antimatter asymmetry and the
theory with that is it definitely too
small that can't be leveraged into yeah
I agree with that
so so when people discover this tiny
difference between behavior matter and
antimatter back in 1964 actually yes
people try to explain this by coming up
with all kinds of theories for that and
then there were experiments one at
Stanford another one in Japan they were
in sort of head-to-head competition for
about 10 years and they proved in the
end that no you can understand why that
happened but the reason how that
happened was not enough to explain the
difference between madinat jumeirah in
the universe at the level of one
billionth of a billionth so is this way
so Miss and Miss by a factor of a
billion but the thing about but I think
is really interesting is our
understanding of particles comes from
looking at patterns and we see all of
these different patterns and what we
have found is that if you find a pattern
in the quark sector like something is is
a very small effect and you look in with
the neutrinos you'll discover that it's
a larger effect so one example of it has
to do with this kind of flavor changing
right and it looks like this may also be
holding out for the the difference
between neutrinos and antineutrinos so
you guys are kind of artists they do the
opposite I know you can't divulge and
perhaps you really don't know but
so the differences that are hinted at in
the neutrino versus antenna treated do
you think that would be enough to
explain the matter/antimatter asymmetry
the connections are a little bit tricky
so I can pass those connections over to
one of the theorists you guys want to
comment on yeah so as we're talking
about today so you want to see that the
matter rabbits and antimatter aunty
rabbits behave differently so that's one
thing we need but another thing we need
is that we start with the same number
yep and turn antimatter into matter
right that's why there's a imbalance
between them do and nobody has seen that
kind of thing the matter turning into
antimatter or antimatter tuning into
matter so people frantically looking for
such a thing also by doing experiments
mostly underground yeah and there's
actually I think slide for that which
that mutant double beta decay yeah so we
can look for a process actually this is
a super chem you can experiment in Japan
but anyway this is the process that you
produce a anti neutrino from some
radioactivity process and if that anti
neutral can turn into neutrino and which
would require it to be its own anti
right that's right so that's only
possible because the neutrino has no
weight active charge right yeah then you
have a process which otherwise wouldn't
happen so people looking for this
special process that you produce anti
neutrino that turns into neutrino and
any interacts with electron at the end
of the day yeah and nobody has seen that
yet because it is cannot happen even
once in 10 to 20 60 years so it's way
beyond the age of universe right that's
why nobody has seen this but if you have
ten to the twenty seven of this stuff
maybe it can happen once a year here so
let make sure I just fully understand
this so so the blue things I gather here
are protons and the proton itself is
undergoing a process where an electron
and an anti-neutrino is being emitted
that's a neutron yeah that's that
nutrient sorry neutrons of that yeah so
so on the left-hand side that is quite
conventional compared to the right hands
that's right so on the left-hand side of
the story the neutron turns into a
proton and spits out electron and
antineutrino yep and another Neutron
does the same thing so in the end is
spits are two electrons in two anti
neutrinos yeah and of course you don't
see neutrinos but you can tell that
something is missing so you know they
are actually neutrinos made in this
process but if the Antonina can turn
into neutrino that's what we hope to see
yep then you know nutrient restructure
disappear from this and all you see is
two electrons coming out right and by
looking at the balance of energy you can
tell that nothing is missing there it's
only just two electrons then you would
say aha
anti neutrino can really turn into
neutrinos see this is actually a
laboratory experiment where you could
literally in some sense have direct
evidence that's right that's right off
matter turning to antimatter and
vice-versa so where does that stand this
this well again people looking for this
I mentioned this is such a way of
process there's a machine that's
relevant to that this is the rori yeah
so this is this is right now the
experiment that is got the the best
limit on neutrinos double beta decay so
we have not seen it and so what happens
is we have to set some kind of a limit
and what it is is it uses an element
which is called tellurium which is an
element that we believe will be a good
place to look for the neutrino list of
lead okay and these are crystals they're
very large crystals that they've grown
and it's a beautiful experiment right so
far
right so so so we know what we need and
there are hints as you say and next week
maybe we'll have new insight into that
let's now turn to cosmology so these are
laboratory experiments things happening
today which may give us insight into a
difference between matter antimatter
yeah how do we leverage this into a
theory that sort of a start at the Big
Bang and take us to today so before
before going to cosmology just to
comment on on these searches for the
difference between meant matter and
antimatter I think we're at the point in
the development of particle physics when
you look in the neutrino sector it sort
of seems more likely from what we know
that there will be these effects there I
mean some people have hinted to that
it's it would be surprising if they're
not there so the way physics has
developed in the last few decades and
people people had all sorts of other
ideas about how to produce the
matter/antimatter asymmetry in the
universe more matter than antimatter but
I think as we understood more deeply the
structure of the theory the processes
that are possible the most plausible
explanation is that it's simply the
natural structure in the minimal
standard model that will do everything
it's not what like you really have to
add lots of ingredients it's already all
the ingredients are sitting there and it
took people a while to appreciate that
and so you think that ultimately that's
where the explanation that seems the
most economical and likely explanation
so I agree with you that neutrinos will
most likely have this asymmetry root in
between neutrinos and antineutrinos
right what I'm not totally convinced is
that even if that is shown that it would
be in any way proved that the neutrinos
are responsible for the
matter/antimatter asymmetry in the
universe and I say that with a heavy
heavy breath because you know Fermilab
is who is paying me so but the truth is
that maybe we are going into that
direction later on but there are many
mechanisms that we can that we fear is
have thought of to try to explain what
it is in this black box that you were
put in there and of course there are
some explanations that are more
plausible than others the neutrino
explanation or the one related to
neutrinos I think is it's beautiful its
elegant it's most likely partly there
but I think it would be most likely
inconclusive so although that doesn't
mean that we have to do the experiments
at Fermi to understand the essence of
what are the properties of neutrinos
because you know we don't know the
neutrino world is so different of what
we are used to the rest of the particles
in the standard model that for example
we don't know if there are more
neutrinos than all the nutrients that we
have seen and so we don't know how they
behave really so even if we put aside
this idea that neutrinos antineutrinos
most likely will behave a little
different from each other and still
maybe that's not the whole story there
still we need to learn a lot about what
these enigmatic particles do and so you
know in the next decade here in the
United States we have we are building
with international collaborations the
most impressive neutrino experiment and
I hope he toshi at least with
yeah so I know that I know that Neil
you've got some as some very iconic
views on what the solution may be I like
to get to in just a moment but Marcella
can we maybe explore a little bit of the
work that you've been doing to try to
fill in that black box try to fill in
our understanding of that process that
takes us from matter/antimatter symmetry
to asymmetry what are the ingredients
that you envision okay so I I could say
there are two possibilities you're under
this much dearest to my heart so I will
go second on that one okay so the first
one has to do with theories grand
unified theories and the idea that maybe
we can think I mean there are some hints
okay what is a grand unified theory I'm
going there so they all be quiet no
please no so the idea is that we know
that there are three forces the
non-gravitational forces you know it's
the electromagnetic force that means
that particles with the same charge
repel each other particles of opposite
charge attract each other
we know that they are what we call
strong forces those are the forces that
keep the protons together to form the
atomic nuclei and they have to be strong
because the protons themselves have
positive charges so they repel each
other and then the last one is what we
call the weak force and the weak force
is what allows for radioactive decays
okay but of course this means that a
proton becomes for example a neutron and
a positron and a neutrino on the side
and those should be weak because
otherwise all the atoms that we know
will disintegrate we need to have mostly
stable atoms so we have these three
forces three or three it depends
we can get into another phase yeah yeah
and another film we can get into another
film the reference I'm not in America
yeah
so these three forces we think then
there may be the possibility that they
unify at some early or early epoch in
the history of the universe and they
become like we see here this got great
grand unified theory so I talked about
Roman Electra weak and weak and strong
and maybe sometime close to the
beginning of the use of the universe or
after the Big Bang they were actually
one mega force one unique force and then
as the universe cooled down then these
forces became different and are the ones
that we see today so that's a grand
unified theory so you saying that the
strengths of the forces actually depends
on the distance over which they're
measured aside and I guess distance is
getting smaller that way so this graph
is a section so on very very small
distances which means very high energies
the three non-gravitational forces their
strengths seem to converge and there is
this data as this theory that we're
looking at right here well depends how
you look at it the best of the eye of
the beholder correct there are some
indirect evidence and this is closer to
your fields I'm trying to be nice so
there is some circumstantial evidence as
you would like to say that this may
happen and if that's the case we
probably would need to have some
extended symmetry of space and time
let's call it supersymmetry string
theory they're there one quite strong
hint would be if you could see proton
decay okay
so proton so far we have looked for a
proton the case and in fact we have we
will look at this experiment from
Fermilab in to South Dakota one option
there would be the dispute enormous and
high
detectors will also look not only for
neutrinos and antineutrinos being
different but also for decay of a proton
into some lighter particles and for
example a positron and that's like a
fairly generic prediction of fairly
generic prediction so far fortunately
maybe we have not seen proton decay and
we know that protons leave at least a
hundred thousand billion billion billion
years which is a lot a lot maybe they
belong so we can set limits like that
because we get them out of experiments
like for example the super-k experiment
the image of Super K was put up just a
few minutes ago and maybe they'll buy a
more Super K and so it's it's an
experiment that is twenty-five kilotons
within the active region that people
look at and it's filled with water so
you can actually see the people going
around in the little boats as they're
cleaning the light detection devices
that are all around the outside and and
it's filled up with water actually
i-i've on an experiment that was
actually filled up with oil rather than
water so I wasn't allowed to go in a
little boat because if you fall out you
sink and oil
but this experiment is the experiment
that has set the very best limits on
proton to cage gives that number that
huge lifetime right because there's so
much water in there that you can you can
set excellent limits on that so you have
to have an enormous detector in order to
be able to do this so if you so you have
this theory then what's the next going
back to the matter/antimatter asymmetry
so proton seems to be stable so far and
we are searching for hints of how to
prove some desire and fight theories but
within this grav unified theories
because we have this this mega force or
these United force there are other
particles that are behaving a bit
different from the ones that we know
today correct and these particles
exactly could be doing something
interesting so turning you know the blue
and orange rabbits in different side
when they go to the box so they were
basically there are two things they can
be doing they are actually making an
asymmetry between the the blue and the
orange rabbits and they are also capable
of basically going on in one direction
so that basically once you went from one
side and you have this asymmetry between
the orange and the and the blue rabbits
it's not possible for them to recombine
and come back and create these universe
at the gut scale so that would be an
interesting possibility and it is there
and of course we have seen we have women
theorists all together
Brian included we have worked a lot of
possible grand unified theories they
behaved different for example if we will
actually observe proton decay we will
have some input about how these models
could be the other the downside of this
is that it would be kind of hard to
really have
gain an irrefutable proof that this is
the reason why the matter/antimatter
asymmetry is different so in my opinion
or at least the thing I have been
working for the last 20 years so I
obviously like it is I'm sure you have
heard about the Higgs boson or the god
particle correct I don't see you but I'm
sure there you are all saying yes so so
the Higgs is mysterious correct and let
me just say in a second one to two
phrases about the Higgs so there is a
Higgs field and Higgs boson the Higgs
field is an invisible field of energy
that is that permeates the whole
universe and you would say ok that's
really not a good thing to convey but
just think about the magnetic field of
the earth that's also an invisible field
ok
that of course is only permeating the
region around the earth and it's
generated by the earth itself when it
spins around its own axis we know that
the invisible Higgs the invisible field
of the magnetic field is there if we
just take a compass correct we will know
with the Higgs it is an invisible field
that it sources itself it doesn't need
anything else
ok and it's everywhere and the reason we
know is there is because we know that it
gives masses to all these particles with
having were talking about the quarks ok
maybe with reception of the neutrinos I
won't go into there so you must all the
particles that form all the matter that
we see today are the basic particles
like quarks and electrons and they and
it stops them from moving at the speed
of light so that the universe as we know
it today can work this happens at
basically this happens at 1/10 of a
billion of a second after the Big Bang
and this is when we see that these are
bubbles of Higgs on and kicks off at
that moment in
in the epic of the universe the Higgs
starts turning on okay and gives mass to
all these particles that we are talking
about the quarks and electrons okay so
this is somewhere where it says Hicks
turns on that's there okay so all what
we were talking before was close up to
the bit man so this kind of the latest
explanation that we have in mind for
when the matter/antimatter asymmetry
actually start appearing even though
it's 10 to the minus 10 seconds that's
late on the scale because you know we
are earlier is the big past sorry win of
course there are two things why I'm very
excited about these possibility first of
all because if you look there it says
David Ronn and CERN and slack and of
that so these are the energy is that we
are proving today with colliders so this
means that if these things happen if we
are recreating the this instance after
the Big Bang at energies or at moments
that are the moments when the Higgs turn
on then we can really explore if this
matter antimatter asymmetry was also
connecting with this idea okay let me
just make sure I fully understand so
you're saying that there's sort of
exotic configurations that involve the
Higgs field that can somehow assure a
symmetric configuration of matter and
antimatter to an asymmetric one
afterwards yeah and you think that in
principle this is true you could
actually recreate it in in Switzerland
you could actually learn about the
details of the theory yeah so that it
will prove it or not the same way that
you know the Higgs boson is the proof
that the Higgs mechanism is right
correct but we only saw we don't we
can't see the whole mechanism but we see
the bottom which means that what we fear
is thought is the right answer
same way here we will measure some
properties related to this moment of the
Higgs turning on maybe at the LHC maybe
at Large Hadron Collider maybe in future
electron posse
accelerators of the future but this is
amazing because now we have you know the
Higgs is turning on at this moment these
these bubbles that we soft turning on
actually very rapidly respond and the
whole universe as we see today is all
heats turn on okay and at this moment
when there we are at the boundary when
this is happening it's what we think
that there are two things happening one
that the Higgs as we were saying talks
differently to matter and antimatter
okay and the other one is what you are
saying that our process is that taking
advantage of the Higgs talking
differently to matter and antimatter
they come and basically they can turn
this asymmetry that the Higgs is capable
to make in a real net asymmetry of
matter antimatter that is here today and
these processes I was told don't say
that word but they're called fatherís is
a Greek word that means slippery it
means what slippery slippery slippery
slippery slippery process that is
happening there
another less valid on process that's
better so it's a slippery process and
this is libery process we need that the
same moment when the Higgs turns on this
is slippery process has to very rapidly
turn off so that all their symmetry we
have created is not wash out and this is
what I think could be the most exciting
explanation for this matter antimatter
asymmetry and you can ask me if it works
in the standard model and I can answer
does it work in the standard no
and again by standard model you're
talking about the ingredients that we
know exist through experiment and the
equations that we've written them
support actors but but obviously you
know I wouldn't be so excited if that
would be the end of the story obviously
okay the point is that as you know
because you like super strings if you
like the purse strings
you like supersymmetry could be in
reality the point is that we do expect
that there would be maybe additional
symmetries in nature or maybe additional
forces that we call dark forces because
we want to connect them with the idea of
dark matter okay
and so so the point is that with what
with the main ingredients that we put
there all these particles along and the
Higgs is not enough because what happens
is first of all the Higgs does not have
a sufficient difference in the ways it
talks to matter than antimatter so we
need to have a bigger difference okay
and the second point is that this
slippery process as I was talking about
they actually turn do not turn off
sufficiently rapidly and the reason we
know that is because we have measured
the Higgs boson mass to be 125 times the
mass of the proton so this this turning
off of this slippery process that is
essential to conserve the asymmetry that
we have generated this is directly
related to how much the higgs mass value
is and we have done these calculations
and we know that the Higgs mass is about
three times too heavy or too large sorry
in order to allow this to happen
but if we have supersymmetry or we have
another dollar sectors that only talk to
us through the Higgs then is an amazing
possibility to have this matter
antimatter asymmetry be an trigger at
the same moment where the Higgs turn on
very early in our universe so so Nia
when you hear that I imagine that that
you said that's an interesting idea
which no doubt is yes but from knowing
you all these years you like things to
be as tight and as minimal as possible
in some sense you have your own idea so
you want to give us some sense of where
yeah so I mean I I was also a huge
enthusiast for these ideas and I think
probably the audience has gained the
impression that after correctly that off
over the last 30 to 35 years the whole
field of theoretical particle physics
has been exploring all kinds of avenues
most of which involve adding more so we
add more particles we add more fields we
had more symmetries we even add more
dimensions of space and more objects
like strings and membranes and so on so
we've been elaborating all kinds of
thing under which we've seen none of
which we've seen it's been a strange 35
years yeah
exploration the basis for it had a very
good foundation which is that adding
more things did work for a certain
period in the history of physics
I mean people initially started with
with the electron and then they
constructed colliders and they found
muons and towns you know some more and
more particles were discovered when you
did more experiments so it was only
natural to think that adding more wood
would somehow continue to be successful
but the truth is the last 35 years it's
not succeeded there hasn't been a single
successful prediction of some natural
phenomenon so just from my own point of
view I have been
attracted by the idea that perhaps we've
seen all the particles we're ever going
to see so if you could show the next
slide you know one one fashionable idea
which has come out of particle physics
and string theory and supersymmetry is
that there is a multiverse you know when
you start adding more and more and more
things to your theory you very quickly
find that you have so many theories
you're you're drowning in theories and
possibilities and the multiverse is the
ultimate sort of drowning in in
possibilities and so I've never found it
very appealing because if you show the
next slide the observations have gone
consistently in exactly the opposite
direction
when we look out so here we are in the
in in the center of the observable
universe sitting in our solar system and
as we look outward in space we're also
seeing back in time to the bit towards
the Big Bang itself and as we look
outward we see the very large-scale
structure of the universe as it was very
very early after the Big Bang and the
observations are reveal a stunning
simplicity you can describe the
large-scale structure of the universe
with essentially one number which tells
you the level of fluctuation that came
out of the Big Bang so the universe is
basically the same in all directions as
far as we can tell
everywhere in space was the same and and
these tiny fluctuations which you can
characterize with a single number
because they're the same on all scales
to to good accuracy this time of the
single number describes the whole
structure of the universe so you can say
the the universe is simpler the universe
is the simplest thing in the universe
but you know the large-scale universe is
the simplest thing in the universe
they're very paradoxical so in in and by
the way this dark energy that has been
mentioned a couple of times
plays a huge role in this because the
dark energy is making the observable
universe finite so in in principle you
could imagine that the universe became
more and more complicated as you went to
large scales and and this would continue
indefinitely and and so the multiverse
picture is like that there's an infinite
infinitely variable universe but in fact
the observable universe due to dark
energy is finite because anything
further than a certain distance is being
carried away so fast by the expansion
that we will never ever ever see it so
all of these facts are sort of pointing
towards the possibility that we live in
an extremely simple universe which is
self-contained Brizzy and possibility
it's the only thing there is this may be
the most likely universe and and by the
way I feel the multiverse picture which
came about as I said because of this
gigantic exploration of possibilities
misses a point about quantum mechanics
you know quantum mechanics also the
world can go through any number of
histories and possibilities but what
happens is that one variant usually one
of them is the most probable right
that's why classical picture of the
world works occasionally you can create
interference between these paths and see
quantum phenomena but general one
possibility dominates so my current
perspective is probably there is one
dominant probability and this and this
is it that's the one we live in so if
you go to the next slide what what is
that possibility
and this relates directly to what you've
heard about earlier matter and
antimatter so if we talk about the
creation of the universe you know is
there anything in nature which is
somewhat which involves creation where
something comes out of nothing and
matter antimatter is the prime example
that you if you switch on an electric
field the electric field pulls an
electron one way it pulls the
antiparticle the other way because they
have opposite charge and joke so even if
you have no particles if you turn on an
electric field you will create a part
that if it's sufficiently strong you
will create a particle antiparticle pair
out of out of nothing
again that's equals mc-squared energy
and the electric field can just and it
creates matter and antimatter in exactly
equal amount so next slide so this is
how we look at this from the outside
okay so we're looking at these two
particle two particles appearing as an
external observer we measure this
process in time we measure it in space
and and and that's what we see we see
these two particles appearing by the way
the blue part of the the positron or and
the electron and the red part the
electron those are classical parts of
this process literally just this
particle flying off to infinity the gray
part is very quantum the the particle
you see the particle if you if you think
about what's going on at that time it's
not going forward in time it's traveling
through space at a fixed time that's
actually not allowed classically okay
nevertheless it happens but so I want to
point out that's the quantum part the
gray part ok next picture
now let's look at it from a different
point of view let's instead of thinking
about two particles think about one
because one of the deepest insights
which occurred in the 30s and 40s
physicists called Zuckerberg and then
fine man was that what is an ante what
is an anti-electron what is an
antiparticle an anti-electron has the
same charge as an electron why because
it's actually the same particle the only
difference is that it's going backwards
in time and so this was a very profound
principal Fineman actually built his
whole machinery for particle physics on
that insight and so from that point of
view forget about the antiparticle
on the left think only about the
electron imagine I had an electron which
went backwards in the external observers
time but forwards in its own time which
goes along its path right then it would
have been the anti-electron it went back
in time went through this quantum region
and emerged as the electron so that
picture is beautiful mathematical a very
precise picture of how a particle
antiparticle pair is created actually
just one particle that's going backwards
and forwards in time so that that is the
closest analogy we have in nature to the
to the formation of a universe so if we
keep going
this is the scenario which we recently
proposed is that the Big Bang was just
such an event where from one point of
view say we're an external observer we'd
say an anti universe came out one side
and the universe came out the other but
that's actually not the deepest point of
view the deepest point of view is that
it's all a single thing and you can
regard the left-hand side as going
backwards in time towards the Big Bang
just as the anti electron was going was
the electron going backwards in time and
the right hand side is the as the
universe going forwards in time
so in a sense the universe causes itself
you can mirror image this picture if you
like and it's exactly the same we could
not tell which of these two we lived in
and where would you put the beginning of
the universe in this way of thinking
about it there really isn't one it just
is it's you see the important point is
the gray region in that particle picture
was quantum it's not classical at that
point it doesn't satisfy our classical
notions of there being a single time for
example so in this picture in the middle
of the picture that's the blurry part
that's the quantum part you shouldn't
say you know the universe wasn't started
by an external agent at a definite time
no the the blurry part is where we don't
even know what time is okay so one
amazingly you can describe all this just
as you can describe with perfect
precision the creation of the
electron-positron pair you can describe
this but you need to use quantum gravity
and when you do this this picture seems
capable of producing the
matter/antimatter asymmetry in the
universe
the U is different than the U bar but
the difference you know we see a
universe full of more matter than
antimatter because we're looking at it
going forwards in time if we were going
backwards in time on the other side
we'd see exactly the opposite and the
guards are eviews caesar complete
symmetry in the God's eye view there is
perfect symmetry if I were living in his
antimatter part yes do I get younger can
no my gray hair back yet Wow no no no
you know you don't know when so in terms
of you can think about it as one causing
the other but actually when the universe
becomes classical you have to identify
the UN you bar there's no distinction
between them there really is no
distinction so how would I decide if
time is going forward that's the
direction in which in the universe is
getting bigger and which galaxies are
forming and you can see that's the same
whichever side you're on no no no no
time exactly the classical parts of this
picture the you and the you BA are
identical so you see that we've gone and
I just want to end this fascinating
conversation going back to Michael you
know we we've been out in two grand
unified theories we've been firing
neutrinos through the surface of the
earth we've been watching a homer and
his ice cream cones and so forth but but
the antimatter is actually with us and
we use it right I mean they're actually
applications for antimatter we're still
trying to explain this asymmetry and
maybe Niels got it maybe more so and
maybe there's some other ideas but but
we actually use it can you just give us
some like concrete application yeah so
everybody's favorite application is of
course to use antimatter's fuel for
spaceships and this is a fact in the
future far in the future it will happen
there is a beautiful image that was
supposed to be flashed up now actually
if I just say the word which I don't
want to say enterprise
no interesting application I had
something more down-to-earth
in mine okay we can talk Star Trek on
our way out but I was actually thinking
about more more concretely of course the
example with the banana is a very good
one yeah because you won't go where I
want you to go but that's fine because
that is actually what positron emission
tomography the banana emits positrons
automatically in humans you can inject
positrons in a way antimatter
by injecting Radio isotopes and then you
can accumulate them in the organ of your
choice which is the bladder but also
occasionally in tumor tissue and so by
watching where these annihilations
happen as the anti electrons are
produced you can actually look inside
the body so it's a very very useful
application sort of down to earth not so
exciting as I have to say the
cosmological implications feel so
exciting right I mean antimatter we're
actually using a zig zag Gnostic tool
and it may be the key to understanding
that perhaps our universe is part of a
much different picture and a bigger
picture than the one that we would have
anticipated so we're going to be waiting
for next week to hear and you know well
maybe they'll let me end on the
following question so imagine we come
back here at the I don't know what are
we 2018 you come back at the 2025 World
Science Festival just very quickly will
we have the antimatter matter asymmetry
of the universe solved by then or are we
looking at something that's you know so
you just give us a what you think I
would say it we may come to the point
that well neutrinos are indeed plausible
explanation for this we may have
discovered by then that the neutrino can
turn into a neutrino
yeah so we can we suffer them yeah by
then we may have discovered the
neutrinos antineutrinos can change the
flavors a different way so we can
distinguish them then it's pretty
plausible then that okay they are the
superheroes yep
so I have to agree with him and I just
want to point out to you that you know I
25 years ago we thought that neutrinos
were massless and that they you know we
understood very little about them and we
now understand a good bit more and I
think by the time we get to 2025 there
is a real chance that we could
understand them as part of matter
antimatter asymmetry but I like to say
that they go from zeroes to heroes I I
definitely hope that we won't see any
difference by them because I've got a
bet a case of champagne riding on the
fact that matter and antimatter behave
the same way well I think that you know
only five years ago we didn't know that
the Higgs was turning on at all now we
are sure it does and so that would be
for me you know exploring what will come
from this Large Hadron Collider and
there is the plan of increasing the
energy to twice what it has there is
plans in different regions in the world
from China to to Europe to many other
places to Japan where we are trying to
think about new tools new accelerators
to study better not only the Higgs but
also for example we don't know if this
is sterile neutrinos are and we can even
have a handle through the experiments
that Janet was talking about or maybe
also by in different regions of
parameter space by looking at them at
colliders extra neutrino by that time
also could be even more energy check us
out on your yeah yeah so I think I
really feel that in the next 10 or 20
years we could see a complete revolution
in physics it won't be more of the same
it won't be more it will probably be
less but a better understanding of one
I'm not going to take that personally No
but a deeper understanding of what we
already know exists and my suspicion is
that when we solve the problem of the
Big Bang singularity which is the
ultimate puzzle and the dark energy
which is the equivalent puzzle in the
future then these other phenomena are
going to be explained as side effects of
the bigger theory well fascinating
conversation ladies and gentlemen please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]